le gouvernement sera-t-il renversé par
une motion de censure sous la vème
république
ça n'est arrivé qu'une seule fois retour
en 1962 petit rappel historique à
l'époque le chef de l'état n'est pas élu
par le peuple mais par des grands
électeurs c'est à dire les députés et
les sénateurs le 20 septembre 1962 le
président charles de gaulle veut changer
tout ça avec un référendum quand il sera
terminé
mon propre septennat ou si la mort ou la
maladie
l'interrompait avant le terme
le président de la république sera
dorénavant élu au suffrage universel
bien sûr ça ne plaît pas aux députés le
4 octobre 1962 ils déposent une motion
de censure pour renverser le
gouvernement confie doux pour être
recevable elle doit être signée par au
moins un dixième des députés
c'est la république qui répondent non à
votre projet car le scrutin
d'aujourd'hui
contrat dans l'histoire
pendant longtemps on dira de nain
politique comment at il voté le 4
octobre
c'est notre honneur de parlementaires
qui est en cause le lendemain le 5
octobre 1962 les résultats du vote tombe
la motion de censure est votée à la
majorité absolue conséquence le premier
ministre georges pompidou et son
gouvernement sont renversés monsieur
pompidou devait être victime du vote de
censure acquis par 280 voix sur 480
enfin presque renversé après le vote de
la censure je suis allé remettre ma
démission au président de la république
qui en a pris acte et comme il a dissous
l'assemblée nationale
il a estimé sans doute qu'il n'était
peut-être pas utile de faire un nouveau
gouvernement pour quelques semaines il
m'a donc demandé de rester en fonctions
jusqu'au début de la prochaine
législature
en réponse à la motion de censure
charles de gaulle décès donc de
dissoudre l'assemblée nationale résultat
des élections législatives anticipées
sont organisés ainsi du plus célèbre
moins connus des électeurs chacun a fait
son choix parmi les options politiques
proposées à tous les français le
problème posé par la dissolution de
l'ancienne assemblée a puissamment
remuer l'esprit public qu'elle figure en
effet les élections donneront tel à la
future assemblée par rapport à
l'ancienne le 25 novembre le verdict des
urnes est sans appel le parti gaulliste
lui nerfs remporte largement les
élections avec plus de 40% des voix la
motion de censure est donc annulée et
georges pompidou conforté en tant que
premier ministre
[Musique]